all right so this is the final challenge
it's a sick sack of obstacles caesar
works with millie a seven-month-old
dachshund whose habit of eating trash
off the ground could have lethal
consequences
this is serious this dog can actually
get hurt caesar's final test will
determine if owner brittany has the
confidence to lead her through a
simulated minefield don't say a word i'm
just gonna guy with energy body language
are you ready i don't know that she's
going to do that with me
that's not something that we then let's
make it happen gotta see it in your mind
i want you to remember the most
important is you're starting in calmness
it's more about you teaching yourself to
become to be patient yeah all right
let's do
it right
the calmness yep
ready
let's try this milly
let's
go nice
slowly
just give a little more space
not so much tension we've talked about
it we've gone through it so i'm aware of
everything that i need to do keep coming
but actually putting that into motion
and keeping myself in a calm state
that's the thing that i'm actually most
nervous about
a little too close that's the obstacle
there she can't touch
slow it down
it's stressful to walk her
remember with the leash the tension
should last one second to second the
most okay
right it's just too direct or to stop
relax the hand
yes yes and you have to remember to
control the nose you'll guide the nose
and the dog will follow
keep coming
walk in the park walk in the park
stop right there
sit there
yes
beautiful
right next to it
yeah yeah yeah yeah she's doing it she's
doing it come on keep coming
[Music]
yep
there you go
yep
[Music]
[Applause]
i felt like a proud mother the first
time this dog has ever attempted half of
these things
and she just did it flabbergasted
actually
yes oh that's the best right that was a
sloppy kid that was a sloppy kiss
i feel pretty proud now i realize how
much my stress and anxiety was really
weighing on millie and that's such a
simple change to get millie to stop
eating things off of the ground and it
makes me hopeful for where we can go
from here so let's celebrate but wait
for me because i really want to
celebrate it winnie way
i want to celebrate the winnie weight
he's ready for this day
this is the way you celebrate with a
winnie dog
that's right i'm a mexican hot dog what
do you think millie
[Music]
this is actually the first time i put a
costume for a dog by the way and i think
millie deserves it because this case is
pretty serious we don't want bad winnies
this is how people think of you by the
way the winnie dogs
caesar thank you for everything i could
not be more happy with the training that
you gave us i'm not afraid to walk her
we are absolutely leaving here today on
the right path we did it we did it yep
yeah thank you thank you let's go all
right come on two weenies
i hope we win an emmy
[Music]
you